After World War II, food shortages plagued Japanese cities.
So, the US supplied wheat flour and encouraged the Japanese to make bread.
One man named Momofuku Ando...
...didn't understand why his people would make bread instead of noodles.
Something that was already part of their culture.
Ando decided to take matters into his own hands...
...and create a new ramen made to last.
He spent a year trying to figure out how to preserve the noodles.
He needed a nonperishable, tasty and easy recipe.
But it was a challenge to maintain robust flavors and unique texture...
...that most people were accustomed to.
It wasn't until his wife was making dinner one night...
...and he threw some noodles in a bowl of hot tempura oil...
...that he realized flash frying the noodles was the answer he had been looking for.
This method not only dehydrated them, it left small perforations...
...that allowed the noodles to recook quickly.
And there you have it.
Instant ramen noodles became an instant success.
So, the next time you heat up a cup of instant noodles,...
...remember you're slurping down a little piece of history.